welcome everyone while we're waiting for
everyone to join and settle down here
are a few testimonials that we have
received we will begin this event in the
next couple of minutes after playing
this video
thank you
over to you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
for that wonderful video
now without any further Ado let's begin
ladies and gentlemen good evening and
hello
I'm a program manager at simply learn by
the name of Vivek peshri and I'm in
charge of ensuring students success in
the IIT kanpur blockchain program and
other technical programs
it brings me great pleasure to welcome
you all to the first ever online
convocation for blockchain which is
being hosted by simply learn in
association with IIT kanpur
the convocation day is after all a day
that every student looks forward to
eagerly since it celebrates all of their
hard work in academics
it also exudes a strong sense of
accomplishment and fulfillment
more importantly a it motivates people
to put in more effort in order to
advance their careers
we shall therefore give it our all to
make this event more exciting and
Unforgettable for you guys
please join me in welcoming our
distinguished Chief guest Professor
Sandeep Shukla
Professor Sandeep Shukla a man who has
achieved so much in the world of
blockchain and education is professor
and head of department for the computer
science and engineering department of
IIT kanpur
he is a joint director of the national
blockchain project funded by the pmo
he is also a program director of The c3i
Hub a Technology Innovation Hub on cyber
security created by the DSD government
of India
Professor Shukla has received the
presidential early career award for
scientists and Engineers from none other
than President George W bush
he is also a fellow IEEE and the ACM
distinguished scientist and speaker
his major research areas are cyber
security
cyber resilience system design risk
assessment
critical infrastructure security and
blockchain Technology
Professor Shukla has published over 300
peer-reviewed conference papers
Journal articles and 10 books as well as
worked as an editor for several noted
journals and Technical Publications
professor
over to you if you have a few words of
advice for the students
first of all thank you for inviting me
and also a huge congratulations to all
the students who completed this course
this course is meant to create Workforce
in India and abroad in blockchain
technology there is a lot of
activities going on in this space I
distributed Ledger technology
blockchain
Wave 3 also is currently being targeted
as kind of related to blockchain
technology so blockchain technology has
an immense opportunity for everybody to
actually take part in and also create
businesses create new solutions to
various problems where there
traditionally there is a lot of friction
for example digital payments digital
payments is one example where there is a
lot of friction between the remittance
uh till the time we actually money gets
settled and credited to the recipients
account uh there are at least four or
five different systems it has to go
through and get uh cleared and get
verified and validated uh whereas
blockchain technology provides a
solution that reduces this friction
reduces the cost of verification and
also allows one to grow the network uh
faster than traditional methods
similarly various government services
that are delivered in Italy like
e-governance services like land record
registry
procurement and many others there we see
that the friction is very high because
of the involvement of various
departments and in various human
human beings which leads to the delays
that which leads to various kinds of
problems
and lack of transparency blockchain
technology can change that quite a bit
therefore it is being seen as a
technology that is that whose time is
Yet to Come which is uh very interesting
because those who are early
starters in this technology and in the
in in their ability to develop
based on this Technology Solutions the
solutions that are also very useful for
people
that they will be actually on the uh on
the uh you know there will be the
beneficiaries of uh of this technology
so so the fact that these students have
chosen to train themselves in lock-in
technology is already a good step
towards uh professional success and of
course a course single course a single
certification course can only teach you
how to get started and there is a lot to
learn and there is a lot of scope and
therefore uh I obviously would uh
tell everybody to keep learning and keep
practicing and keep developing and
hopefully this technology will become
part of your career growth and part of
your profession and that will be
considered a success for this program so
again congratulations to everybody and I
hope that you enjoyed this course and
hopefully you will be making a good use
of this course
thank you Professor for those
informative words
next stop we have Mr Abhishek Mukherjee
who is the senior director of learner's
success at simply learn
as a head of learner's success Abhishek
is responsible for ensuring our Learners
have the best learning experience across
the entire Journey
prior to Simply learn Abhishek has
served in operations and strategy
leadership roles at OU and Max
Healthcare
in an earlier life Abhishek was an
advanced analytics consultant at
McKenzie and Company helping a wide
array of clients across India Middle
East and the US
Abhishek
owe to you for a few words
thank you thank you Vivek I hope I'm
Audible
yes
thanks a lot uh thank you so much
Professor Shukla I think it's always
enriching and inspiring to hear your
thoughts it was amazing to know about
the wide applications of blockchain
technology and what the future holds for
us right
um I would also like to start by
congratulating all of you graduates
today on completing this rigorous
program
thank you for everything you've put into
this program
um you're very much a diverse and
accomplished group as we can see uh we
have Engineers phds mbas analysts and so
on uh from a multitude of Industries and
it's a range of work experience
in addition now you all have the IIT
kanpur certificate along with the
knowledge that you've gained through the
program and are going to be the movers
and shakers of tomorrow
but as they say now the fun begins
but before that I hope you're sharing
your achievements today with your family
your friends and with your colleagues
you can truly Inspire them all
I would like to say that all of you are
a part of an elite Circle who've
achieved something amazing
I wish to leave you with a quote from
somebody I followed that's Peter Drucker
it says that the best way to predict the
future is to create it and that's what
you all are in the midst of twin not
only creating your own future but
creating the future of your
organizations and the society at Large
with that I wish you all the best we
would love to keep in touch please reach
out and let us know how you're advancing
in your careers we would also love to
keep you active in our community
there are hundreds of Learners that are
coming behind you for you know for the
IIT Khan personal program you can be
mentors to them while continuing on your
own journey and as Professor Shukla said
this is just the starting of your
blockchain journey I wish you all the
best and hope to stay in touch thank you
thank you Abhishek for those wise words
next up is an I.T professional with more
than 16 years of experience
he is killed in a variety of toolkits
and domains
he's working in the blockchain space for
the past six years
he has built a few use cases in
Industries like government health care
and supply chain
he enjoys blogging posting webinars and
imparting knowledge to others just like
he has done to all of you here
please extend a warm welcome to Mr
vivekar a senior blockchain trainer
Vivek uh over to you for a few words
we make uh hello everyone good morning
good evening uh I will try to make it
very short
all right first of all shout out to you
all for doing this whole course and
having a Saturday client
so I still remember when we took the
very first batch of this blockchain the
very first question which I was asked
like what is the difference in the
Bitcoin and blockchain that's the very
first question the people asked me and
there are still the same question come
in almost all the batches now uh I
hopefully know like after going through
this whole course now you understand
right so blockchain like Bitcoin is just
a one application or blockchain but
blockchain is more more than Bitcoin
just clicked over right so as you now
all know right so blockchain is going to
evolve it is going to benefit all the
sector name any sector in the world is
going to be uh benefited by them right
Healthcare sector supply chain and more
importantly government sectors right and
if you see all the government across the
globe if you talk about India States
Europe Asia pack all the governments are
actively working on the blockchain space
some are evaluating blockchain some has
implemented some some kind of use case
in the blockchain especially in India's
right the Andhra state government right
so they are moving the land record to
the blockchain so blockchain has a big
potential along with that yes we have
certain challenges so blockchain has to
evolve it has to get mature we have
scalability issue with the blockchain
which will be sorted out soon right but
I think the potential is huge in the
blockchain space I think you have choose
the right path for you starting in the
space and as mentioned by social plus
like this this course is starting of the
blockchain journey for you this is not
Android so you all are starting this
journey right so keep learning keep
exploring start working on use cases for
the actual blockchain whether it's a
ethereum blockchain hypervisor fabric
multi-chain any kind of blockchain so I
wish you all the best for your teacher
thank you everyone
it's nice of you
now moving on all right let me remind
you of the journey that has led to this
significant accomplishment
you've attended live classes every
weekend or eight to nine hours
sometimes more
as you've progressed to this program
you've invested hundreds of hours
learning through online self-paced
videos as well as complete more than 20
assisted practice exercises and end of
Learners evaluations
by using this information you completed
your Capstone project and you gain new
skills as well and now we are here
to do this in all honesty a lot of
dedication and passion was needed your
tenacity and encouragement of your loved
ones are appreciated
I want to take a moment to recognize and
thank each and every one of you
give yourself a round a round of
applause
moving on
now it's time to recognize each and
every student who has successfully
completed a program
I'd like to quickly summarize for
everyone the number of qualified
students present
we have 460 students who have
successfully completed the blockchain
certificate program
we also have a few of our graduates who
will be sharing their experience with us
as we proceed
prior to congratulating each of our
graduates I'd like to apologize in
advance if I mispronounce anyone's name
please do not worry if you have
accidentally missed out your names this
wasn't done on purpose
you can contact us at any time and we
will make room for you in the upcoming
convocation event
now moving on to our graduates
even if we can move on to the next slide
are you able to hear me
Abhishek are you able to hear me
thank you we can hear you I think thank
you
I think so you're facing a slight uh
technical issue all right these
parameters uh while we get that sorted
out
yeah and maybe we should try
um
moving the house taxes
okay let's give it a couple of minutes
and I think so we should be sorted in a
few minutes
let's take a little bit longer and there
we are thank you so much for fixing it
all right we got a good technical team
as well thank you so much everything up
all right so let's begin all right uh
first up Swati
vinod
Satish
pradipta
Shruti
Baba
Prashant
gopinath
congratulations to all of you
amol
Ethan
Joseph
tanu
Kunal
Girish
chandu
Rajesh
vinay congratulations to all of you
aniket
Shankar
Kiran
aruni
asudeva
Ashwin
anirban
abhilash
Sagar
Aditya congratulations to you as well
Vishnu
Gopi
meghna
foreign
congratulations to all of you again
we gone
deep
Dr Meenakshi
Central
as well
Satish
sambit
Rana
ramachandra congratulations to all of
you
Abhishek
Ravi
hey
lokesh
Sagar
twinkle
pesh
Sunil
Rajesh
Suresh
congratulations to all of you
before I proceed any further
I would like to call upon Mr Shaker Lily
to share his thoughts with us
Arun could you please make uh Mr Sheikh
kill the panelist
good evening Shaker how are you doing
today
unfortunately we are not able to hear
you say good I think so you're not
connected to the audio can you please
check
yeah able to hear me now fantastic loud
and clear yeah
thanks for the opportunity and uh so
first of all it feels great to be here
and grade two year Vivek search voice
after a long long time and also feels
even better to see him in person because
we have only been hearing his voice for
four months from November last year till
February this year but finally it feels
great to put their face to the name so
that's it's great I think there were a
lot of
positives to take from this course I
think one thing that really stood out
for me is that this course actually
forced me to push my boundaries and kind
of helped me overcome some mental blocks
which I had before I had started this
session
so uh okay I'll just give you an example
so I had done coding more than a decade
and a half back
okay so I was a bit skeptical whether I
was able to complete the coding and the
Capstone project on time
explained all the concepts to us both
functional technical the architecture
Etc it was perfect and I was able to
complete the Capstone project on time
and to add I actually used quite a few
new functions and if else conditions in
the solidity program which actually were
not taught explicitly so I kind of
raised my own path so it felt quite nice
mentioned at the beginning of this
convocation
blockchains that were evolving space and
the future looks very exciting so yeah
I'm sure that this course will benefit
all of us in the future so thank you IIT
kanpur thank you everyone for this
wonderful course and looking forward to
staying in touch with you
thanks Vivek thank you so much for the
Skyward Shaker it's good to hear from
you
all right so now we'll move ahead with
the list of graduates
partha ramachandra raghavendra
srikant has been samya Chandra
Ankit
Johan
hemachandra
congratulations to all of you
Vivekananda
Akshay
abhinav
Shiva Kumar
Shivam
Suraj
Banu venkatesan
congratulations to all of you
put it
shabir Naveen
devia
amaresh akshat
ramiz abhilash
anshul
congratulations to all of you again
moving on
utkarsh
is
Vikram
rajal
Kishore
Amit
Lemuel
congratulations to all of you
be here
last year
Abhishek
ishtan
Pavan
Ava
Nikon
Satish
zygon
shamla sorry about that uh
senthil Kumar
shrikant
Jaya
mohini
Siddhartha santu
Summit
nambi
Rahul arundhati congratulations to all
of you
moving on
angad
eshwar
odnima
through
Tony
yashoda
chigna Vishal
Pasha
gaurav
um
Swati
arsha
Padma Priya
sangram
Aishwarya
Balaji Prashant
chenish and Monsoon congratulations to
all of you
now before moving forward we have
another learner who would love to share
his learnings
I would like to invite Mr amaresh sahu
to share his learnings
Aaron could you please make ambrish uh
the panelist
hi everyone good morning good evening
thank you for making it to today's event
yeah
uh thank you uh basically uh like this
uh IIT kanpur program of blockchain uh
literally I would say it's my turning
point in my professional career being
very honest because uh even though I was
introduced to blockchain uh through
cryptocurrency and trading
2018-19 but I got the real uh knowledge
and the feel of the power of blockchain
Technology through the IIT kanpur course
the first session we had with Sandeep
sir uh sir had categorically told this
is just the basics and you have to dig
deep into it uh really a lot you have to
work hard a lot so uh even though
whatever was taught was just the basics
and I dug deep into each and every
aspect of it in fact I was off coding I
was not into codings in the last 10
years but uh
realizing the power which blockchain has
in the coding aspect I really really
felt it's like it was like I was I
discovered Wildfire so I went into it
deep and started doing projects after
projects uh searching YouTube searching
other resources and uh I've done four or
five projects of my own uh apart from
the Capstone project which simply learn
had and it's really amazing I'm
discovering many solutions which can be
of practical use in today's date so uh
this course was really amazing and
thanks to the curriculum which was
designed which is pretty in-depth and it
is very diverse actually uh every aspect
of blockchain starting from the basics
is covered up to uh you have harder
sorry you have uh this thing we have a
hyperledger fabric also and all those
things which generally a course does not
uh have which is very pretty specific to
certain aspects of the course whichever
courses I saw outside so simply not has
done an amazing thing and really our
thank the faculties starting with Vivek
sir of course he took our hyperledger
fabric part uh it was pretty amazing he
took three hours session but that was
crisp clear and it was super amazing
ishmit Singh sir he took the uh this
thing uh the coding part of uh
blockchain that was really interesting
and the personality he is he really
influenced me and uh attracted my
attention towards blocking blockchain
technology and of course now when I am
into the market with my blockchain
degree from IIT kanpur it is a big big
positive uh for me because uh anyways
people judge with your knowledge but
yeah the cover of the book is beautiful
then people tend to open the book after
that so IIT kanpur uh really uh it is a
big branding for me in today's date and
really thanks and uh each and every
rupee which I invested in the course uh
it it is is paying off really well and
last but not the least I have already
got three job offers in web 3 Space 2 as
blockchain trainers and one as a
blockchain developer uh so I feel really
lucky that it was just a coincidence
something like that but I registered in
the course and uh literally flying high
and thanks to all your guidance and
support thanks a lot uh simply learn
thanks a lot IIT confer thank you
amrish thank you for those kind words
I'm sure some of these words are really
inspirational to all the other Learners
thank you so much thank you
all right uh moving on
to the remaining list of graduates we
have ritesh
Rajesh Krishna
in a
thin
oinks anupam
Narendra
Bharat
Saiyan
venkateshwara
Aryan
Roshan
anushree
semi
eptenine
Heroes
Anish
Raj abhinav and Raji congratulations to
all of you
manikandan Tushar
chaitali
Akash
Abhishek
Ajay
suyash
Giant
Raja gopal Malik
Dinesh
foreign
congratulations to all of you
Akshay
Baba
sheetal
Dash
Remy
Priyanka Manoj
daughter
ancient mrinal
sriraj lohit
aravind
Bijou vigneshwaran chindukuri parag
PA sakshi
Abdul Ramesh
Manu saroj congratulations to all of you
kalyani
ashwani riddhi
chin mate Rana lokendra
Aman Santiago
supradeep sudhanshu
devanand
Deepak
Arun
arinathan devraj
chandrashekar Ajay
Amai
nikhil
anandraj mandavi
satyajit and sahil congratulations again
to all of you
foreign Swami
anirudh saket
Basu
Shivam
Sachin
Adnan
anshul
Rani
Shiva
Vignesh
pratik rumana
aniket
Sandeep
nikhil
krishnanu
prajwal
Sachin paskaran Ashish congratulations
again
moving on
himanshu Bilal
Kumar
Arun
dheeraj
nabila
Sharon
Karthik
a Kumar
Shruti
Arun
Harish
abigyan
yogendra
arbaaz Deepa
Jyoti rithvik and giri congratulations
to all of you
now before we proceed further next we
have Mr ketan who is going to share how
blockchain has made an impact in his
life
Aaron if you could please make ketan the
panelist
an I think so you've already been made
the panelist wait to see here if you
could please switch on your video so
everyone can see while you're speaking
as well
Ethan are you able to hear me
hello yes we can hear you Captain but we
cannot see him yet yeah yes I'm just
trying to see the video is not coming
wait a minute sure sure take your time
one second
yeah you can be able to see me right uh
my voice is clear
yes absolutely we can see you and hear
you as well loud and clear yes yeah
first of all I would definitely like to
thank you Vivek thank you sudeep sir and
all other Federalists also about that
okay to make this blockchain as a
starting point of the course which we
started because I see my journey of
blockchain actually like how the
internet was there in 1995 the same
Revolution is coming up now in
blockchain in next decades so what I see
in Internet it you able to hear my voice
so now we started actually what uh when
I when I joined simply learned just to
brief you about that because I'm coming
from a non-technical background I'm a
chartered accountant cost accountant and
MBA so I did the technical side of the
course without having much
impacted what understand it because I
was love
for crypto a lot of the businesses so I
would like to learn the technology what
is falling behind and after joining this
course I came to know because I see a
future in non-technical background as
well because what I see the blockchain
is going to revolutionize the industry
in a startup industry in your mobile
applications as well as in the
accountancy profession in which I am
there so where the VC Double Entry
transactions instead of double leg you
can see a triple entry transaction like
debit credit and the validation happens
on the go so the blockchain will going
to change the complete Revolution and
which is requirement today for the
government as well as for the private
sectors to move on at the real-time
transactions and the learning which I go
and since I understand Erp and all that
actually so the programming was easy for
me also when I did the Capstone project
on solidity it was fantastic learning
from all the professors and the
knowledge which I gained and I want to
revolutionize I want to see not as just
a coder but I am looking into a startup
project and a startup industry how we I
can make that changes what I learned
from IIT and to grow the industry uh in
the accountancy profession as well as in
the medical like you see Medical in
history medical industry or the real
estate transactions where everywhere now
the blockchain is must because it will
solve lot of your problems transparency
will be easy and the security of the
transactions will be much faster and
much smoother so that's that's a good
great learning great experience with the
simply learn as well as the IIT and it
is this is just a beginning for me
actually where I involved myself and I
would love to be part of in future
business opportunities and the
profession with the simply learn and
iits in the blockchain thanks thank you
very much for all this
thank you so much Caitlin I'm sure your
words are inspirational to all the
budding Learners that we have all right
thank you so much yeah yeah thank you
really great to know that somebody from
an accounting background a non-technical
background was able to relate to the
course was able to get so much out of
the course I um I'm really happy to hear
the efforts you put in I think this this
convocation is is getting streamed live
on LinkedIn and YouTube I'm sure a lot
of people who are from a non-technical
background and are probably trying to
evaluate if this is the right Next Step
for them will will be will be helped by
your uh by your story
definitely and I will definitely want to
give that message okay it's not just a
technical side where people should come
up with the blockchain because
blockchain is going to change in all so
you need to be a functional side also
the finance people or non-technical
people also can gain the exposure and
great learning because next decade is
going to be changing the complete
Revolution I see in audit profession
also it is going to change because our
traditional audits are going out of the
course and it will be coming up into the
blockchain audits with the systems and
all the in places so that's where my uh
at this age also occur if I'm gaining
that exposure because I see I want to
gain that and yes there is no no age bar
for Learning and anything you should
keep on learning at each stage and any
new technology which is a revolution
which will come up will be a boost for
our industry in the global environment
inspirational between and I'm absolutely
right I mean the best Solutions will
emerge when both domain experts and
Technology experts will come together
and this is just an example of us thanks
a lot thank you thank you so much again
thank you all right uh well uh we'll
move on now with the remaining graduates
all right so let's get back yes uh let's
start nihir
Sanjay
sort of Supreme
pranav
nitish
above
Krishna Kumar Biju Ana
venkata
sujit
Jay
park again
soham
Chandra Rohit
raghav
Surya
Shivam holipaka
prakash
inder Kaur
congratulations to all of you
sravani a beak omal kartiken Marti came
sarapu Pratap
ravindra Ravi Kumar novel nagendra
Manisha
sorry Dr Manisha
Karan ITA Anand Krishnan meghna
deep pankaj abhinav
pradeep
Suresh congratulations to all of you
foreign
arnab Amitabh nitin and India
congratulations again to all of you
moving on
Swati
Avinash
gaurav
chandrashekar Deva sabarish
sindhuja
satwik Mahesh excuse me
arika
love deep
Anish
a
ritesh larger Manju palak palmshi bharti
prati nikhil Tushar congratulations
again to all of you
moving on
Amit
ishan
Aditya
ananya Rajesh
umajid rupak
ushi
jangala Diljit
Sadaf
chithi abhijeet rithik Ranjit Ricardo
tan garage
disha minojin pasuki Vilas
congratulations to all of you again
Rohan
pankaj
radeep atarwa
ronak
Niraj Jonathan
Yash
Vikram
Psy tanu kandula Atul Raj Vikram
brijesh aniket anurag and Rajesh
congratulations to you as well
moving on to the next slide
you
suryakanti samid vishwanatha Bala
Vignesh Rohit
Krishna
debaker rushali
Tushar
IA ashutosh
sumesh
Ganesh zeenat
Marshall
s BJ
srijit Vijay
Sindhu congratulations to all of you
and of course the last list of names
that we have kirish
saish
Prashant
chaitanya
nitesh and Dinko
that's the end of our that's the end of
the list of Learners that we have thank
you so much and congratulations again to
all of you
warm congratulations to all graduates
all right uh before we end this okay uh
there is one more learner all right that
we would like to call upon who would
like to share his thoughts right uh Mr
Prashant uh if you would like to share
your thoughts please Arun could you
please make Mr Prashant the panelist
I think so uh prashanti already made the
panelist can you hear me
Prashant if you're speaking we are not
able to hear you
yeah Prashant you need to unmute
yourself I can see you're still on mute
I think so he may be facing a few maybe
a technical issue Prashant uh if you're
speaking you're speaking in mute you
will have to hit the mic the unmute
button on the bottom of your screen to
be able to speak
all right not a problem I was on the
call sorry
not a problem Prashant we can hear you
now
yes
actually I was not having any experience
on coding
so I just joined being that there will
be a
good future what is because somehow I
completed the course and Capstone
project also very deep with a very
difficulty let's see what will happen
for your future thank you so much for
joining in and sharing your experience
and thoughts
all right thank you very much
you're welcome
all right uh now moving on all right
we've got two sets of awards lined up
for today
right
now we are aware that each and every one
of you here is an achiever because this
path has not been simple however
only a select few students went above
and beyond to demonstrate their
competitive spirit
the first category of the award is the
scholar award
here we facilitate the top three
performance in terms of completing their
live classes projects and assessments
with the highest cumulative scores
congratulations to
Abhishek
and ishan Agarwal
let's give them a round of applause for
all the efforts
all right moving on next
the second set of awards which
recognizes Learners who are able to
complete the program end to end in the
shortest duration
we call them the speedrunners
congratulations to Kunal khatri Rohan
and Vilas Curry
please give them a round of applause for
all the efforts
thank you so much
all right moving on next is the team
right so now what I'm going to do is I'd
like to introduce you to the group of
people who work tirelessly behind the
scenes to ensure that you have the best
learning experience
putting a face to these names you have
heard and interacted with over the
previous years the purpose behind this
first I'd like to introduce our faculty
team
I would like to take this opportunity to
thank our faculty for constantly
supporting us throughout the program
they have been the major pillars of your
experience and would like to call out
each faculty and thank them on your
behalf
Prashant sahu
Deepak
chandran jagadish
now before I proceed we have a faculty
here who would like to share their
thoughts Aaron could you please uh pass
on the panelists right so Mr Prashant
sahu
good evening Prashant are you able to
hear me
yeah I'm doing good and I hope that
you're also doing good
and yeah so hi everyone and
congratulations to all the people who
have completed this course successfully
uh background of Applause I would say
from everyone and you'll have done a
fantabulous job if I would say uh I
remember again so as I said like when I
started this uh training to the people
uh people were very much afraid that
they have been from a very Diversified
backgrounds like hey Prashant can I be
able to do this can I be able to make it
up till the last I would just say sit
calm enjoy you're gonna go and try to
make it up and see today I could see the
list of people like there are a lot of
people who have been present here who
have completed this course successfully
from a diversified backgrounds so I
would wish every one of you to go ahead
and practice as much as you can like
whatever you have learned and keep
practicing as much as you can and that's
gonna give you a bright future going
forward with respect to this blockchain
technology because you know this
technique technology is in a greater
demand and if you just have the right
skill set that will definitely be
helping you out to go and try to thrive
in this technology and yeah like even if
it is ethereum or a hyper Ledger or a
multi-chain or applications so whatever
whatever you have learned from this
entire simply learned course just go and
try to keep learning and just explore to
a different case studies go and try to
help it out like how we can make or how
we can leverage this blockchain
technology and make the things go in the
right direction and once again
congratulations to all the people who
have made it who have done all these
things uh with a with a proper interest
with all those Capstone project and
everything uh keep up and all the very
best for your future keep learning keep
exploring keep excelling and yeah that's
it from my end thank you everyone and
over to you Vivek thank you so much
Prashant for those words
yeah
all right uh now we'll move on to the
next slide uh we would also like to
thank all our Master Class instructors
who are part of the IIT kanpur faculty
facilitating us with different
interesting topics every month
uh before I actually can you please
change the slide
I don't know I think so I can face in a
slight technical problem I don't know if
you can hear me if you could please see
in the slide
connects
I don't know are you able to hear me
so you're facing a small technical issue
uh just bear with us for another couple
of minutes and uh we'll resume with this
wonderful convocation
thank you so much all right so again uh
Professor Sandeep Shukla because who's
been taking a lot of Master Class with
us thank you so much professor professor
k.s venkat and Professor rajat Agarwal
as well thank you so much for all the
topics that you'll have covered
now moving on to the next theme which is
the core team at simply learn first up
is the learner success team
now here is a team who is responsible
for all the sessions and resolving all
the tickets that you post now many of
you would have interacted with it
directly or indirectly as well
Uma Devi
divyanshu bhatti
sahima munir
kavya SRI manjunath and Imran Shah thank
you so much for supporting all our
learners
now next up is the faculty and Alignment
team or as we call them the fnat
they are responsible for hand-picking
and getting us the best trainers
the whole and soul of our IIT kanpur
faculty Iman Rashad thank you so much
Amy for providing us with such quality
trainers
moving on uh next is the productive
this team is the brains behind curating
the program and structuring it they have
been the bridge between simply learn and
IIT kanpur and drivers for the program
Ankit Kumar
Abhishek Jain
Mayan tiwari and Anand kaswan
thank you team for all your efforts
is the content team the team responsible
for all the content and curriculum that
we see in the terms of live virtual
classes as well as self-learning videos
rajat Agarwal
Ravi tulsiani and Smith
thank you team for all your efforts
last but not least the leadership team
who regulates the direction of all the
programs oversees the learner's success
team as well a big thank you to you
chandran Agosh
Naveen srinivasan and myself Vivek
peshwik
well uh please all right let's take a
moment and thank and upload the entire
team's efforts thank you everyone so
much
now this brings us to the end of our
first edition of the online convocation
for IIT kanpur's blockchain program in
association with simply learn
each and every graduate all the very
best for their future and we believe
being aspirational is the first part of
being successful
you have come here with an aspiration
and dream and we are pretty sure many of
you will excel in different streams of a
career
we would like to thank all of you for
actively rating us on social media
platforms
in addition to those who have just
shared their experiences with us
you are overjoyed and thrilled to see
all of your positive comments about our
program
posted on wish various social media
channels additionally we have gotten
feedback that has inspired us to work
harder and make Corrections and move
forward to provide you with a Better
Learning environment
now I know we said uh it's almost the
end of our convocation but uh it seems
like there is one more person who would
love to speak and share his experience
uh Arun if you'd like to pass over the
panelists rights to Prasad Au please
Prashant a right who we yes
and if time permits we should also allow
uh Mr Radha Krishnan
yeah I think so we can spend a couple of
minutes uh
I don't know if you can just pass over
the panelists right Supersoft hey
I think so I don't know are you there
can you hear me
now if you're not able to make Prasad
maybe we can just pass on the panelists
rights to Radha Krishna that's all right
you can pass on the rights to rather
Krishnan who would also love to share
his experience
yeah another Krishna
hey Radha Krishna good evening
good morning and good evening to all
thank you so much for giving an
opportunity to me nice to see all the
teaching members primarily Professor
Shukla
and always see him in videos now I'm
seeing him in life and Vivek thank you
so much
uh I wanted to see you know Deepak but
somehow missing him he is the most
passionate Mentor I've ever seen he's
the most passionate on the way he
articulate things and the way he teaches
he actually spell bonds I mean I love
his teaching I have spoken to him as
well but unfortunately he's not here
okay
um coming back to about myself
I have 25 years of experience in IIT
industry I'm an Enterprise architect
I was based out of Dubai and I was
working for a company called GBM which
is IBM partner I've been selling IBM
Technologies Enterprise architect uh I
am a cloud computing uh guy the data
scientist
but we were all doing the data science
projects sorry and cloud computing and
other infrastructure projects but I
recently moved to us six months back as
a CTO of a company O3 Technology
Solutions
uh we are into digital Transformations
uh side of it so uh I had you know I'm
I'm being an Enterprise architect
I had knowledge about all the
Technologies the framework but basically
I was looking for learning the
blockchain
uh
platform when I was just when I did all
my research and finally I landed up in
simply learn because I did compare with
all the competing uh platforms but
finally simply learn I think is the only
one which is actually
covering all this you know the subjects
and the components and end-to-ends and
then I finally uh selected simply learn
and it was an exhaustive almost four to
six months of you know the continuous
learning videos uh assignments and
quizzes and then Capstone projects
um
starting from Basics from blockchain and
today I compare there is a phenomenal
Improvement in my knowledge
okay and then uh coming back to my
journey I moved to us and being a CTO
we liaison collaborated with multiple
companies and then we also roll out our
own products so we rolled out an own
product which is uh nft so I mean
blockchain is an option you cannot have
you know everything in blockchain and
then go and you know roller products you
know it can be uh tokenization it can be
nfts it can be you know cryptos so we
have chosen nfts and then we have our
own nfts came out with the nfts a
product called uh O3
enough Keys which is a customer loyalty
program
so all the fashion bands in the premium
fashion brands we go through them and
then uh talk to them and then there is a
traditional royalty program which is
currently on the web too and then this
is a web 3 based uh Customer Loyalty
program where you know the premium
Brands like uh
h m or you know the atomic and roll up
their nfts make their own nfts or they
can fall back on the on the famous
collections the BYT collections Whoever
has got the you know famous collections
they are eligible for some the bonus
redemptions and ten percent twenty
percent so so this is this is a product
that we rolled out so the coming to the
point that I just I requested Abhishek
and we make that you know give me an
opportunity to talk to the Forum thank
you so much for everything the content
and the people the mentors
amazing amazing journey so thank you so
much for everything it enabled me in
technology it enable me in collaborating
with partners and going to the customers
um uh there is a huge transformation
myself from where I started my journey
the confidence uh everything I mean I
really appreciate this thank you so much
for everyone again I wanted to see
Deepak but I am missing him amazing
passionate mental I will thank you so
much pass on the message
all right but it's uh thank you so much
for sharing those words yeah I mean it's
good to know it's this program has made
an impact in your opinion thank you so
much
and I'm fascinating to see the diversity
again right
from accounting folks from a
non-technical background to hardcore
coders to somebody like Radha Krishna or
the CTO leadership decision making
position just to say that the course is
appealing to a wide section of Learners
really happy to
hear and see that thank you
thank you so much
great uh well uh again we have you know
honor we are on a limited time so again
so before we add this event all right I
wouldn't leave you with one thought for
today
we are now you are now our ambassadors
for the program offered by simply learn
and IIT kanpur
people will now imitate your actions
looking to you as a beacon of success
we ask that you participate in our
communities and publish relevant
information for the upcoming students
please keep us informed of your success
and tag us in your post so that we can
both rejoice and ensure that the future
students are on the proper role
one spot please accept a sincere
gratitude for selecting simply learn as
your partner in skill development
I want to thank again everyone again
here for coming to this event
with that
we come to the end of this event
good night and good luck everyone
cheers